[Music]
wilmer valderrama makes his first public
appearance since X Demi Lovato's
apparent drug overdose on Saturday the
38 year old actor stepped out for a good
cause
attending the kind Los Angeles coming
together for children alone charity
event in La Wilmer looked handsome in a
blue oxford shirt black pants and
loafers to support immigrant and refugee
children everyone goes through ups and
down I'm in a new chapter in my life
Wilmer stayed by Demi side as she
recovered at cedars-sinai Medical Center
a source told ET quote he is getting
better day by day with the help of her
family friends and Wilmer the sorry not
sorry singer broke her silence since
being hospitalized over the weekend the
25 year old pop star took to Instagram
writing I want to thank God for keeping
me alive and well
I now need time to heal and focus on my
sobriety and road to recovery if I would
have continued down that road it would
have been I don't know if I'd be here
today
[Music]
[Applause]